j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
débat de société volontairement décalé
de l'actualité du jour et je vous
propose de nous plonger dans ces images
générées par de l'intelligence
artificielle le pape François vous le
voyez en doudoune Emmanuel Macron
éboueur en pleine crise du ramassage de
l'eau poubelles Barack Obama et Angela
Merkel qui font des pâtés de sable voilà
c'est celle-ci nous ont fait rire
évidemment mais comment identifier le
vrai du faux l'IA peut-elle devenir
l'outil idéal pour manipuler l'opinion
il y a aussi cette question le marché de
l'art le la peinture la photo le cinéma
est-il menacé par ses œuvres créées par
des robots avant d'en débattre on
regarde comment des journalistes ou des
associations remontent aux origines des
images Jonathan Dupriez
siège de l'AFPA Paris dans cet open
space un pôle d'une dizaine de
journalistes vérifiés de fausses
informations qui circulent sur le web
ce jour-là marin remonte la piste d'une
vidéo partagée plus de 2000 fois sur les
réseaux sociaux on y voit Vladimir
Poutine en avion escorté par des
chasseurs selon les internautes le
maître du Kremlin se rend à un sommet de
pays émergents en Afrique du Sud tout en
bravant le mandat d'arrêt de la Cour
pénale internationale cette vidéo
montrerait que Poutine est un homme fort
qui ne se soucie pas en fait de ce
mandat d'arrêt et qui se déplace malgré
tout vers l'Afrique du Sud ou aura lieu
ce sommet donc dans les commentaires les
gens y croient tous avec des captures
d'écran qu'il passe dans un moteur de
recherche marin retrouve la vidéo de
Poutine datée de décembre 2017 sur le
site d'un journal italien sérieux et là
on se rend compte que la vidéo a été
publiée
sur le site du courrier de la Serra un
article accompagne la vidéo on y apprend
que Vladimir Poutine s'est en fait rendu
en Syrie une recherche en russe
permettant ensuite de retrouver la même
vidéo sur Spoutnik un média de
propagande du Kremlin et publié dans la
même zone donc vers le 13 décembre 2017
c'est informations seul n'est pas
suffisamment fiable mais permet à Marin
de rechercher d'autres sources qui
confirmeraient se déplacement une des
pêches AFP de 2017 le confirme enfin
après deux heures d'investigation
l'information est publiée dans un
article web accessible en ligne les
fausses informations et les rumeurs
circulent bien plus vite que le enfin
que le temps que ça prend pour rétablir
la vérité donc nous on essaie d'aller
vite et c'est vrai quand on arrive à
faire une vérification
solide qu'on publie rapidement il y a un
certain satisfaction parce que on se dit
que peut-être ça va ralentir un petit
peu la viralité de cette info
informations comme marin 140
journalistes de l'AFP dans le monde
s'emploie quotidiennement les fausses
informations une mission devenue
incontournable pour les médias
traditionnels mais qui reste délicate au
vu du volume à traiter
dans le monde que ça ne suffirait pas
tant la désinformation est largement
partagée à l'évidence
maintenant on voit quand même depuis
quelques années où on existe que de plus
en plus le terme de fake checking
l'existence des facts shaker dans le
grand public comment ça faire à faire
son chemin dans l'esprit des leaders
politiques aussi si la manipulation de
l'information provient majoritairement
des réseaux sociaux les journalistes
doivent aussi faire face à une fiabilité
parfois relative des sources officielles
disclose médias d'investigation en ligne
à but non lucratif ces spécialisé dans
ce type d'enquête d'une certaine façon
péril alors la demeure au sens où des
sources officielles des sources de
confiance
manie aujourd'hui la contre-vérité ou ce
que certains appellent la Poste vérité
et vont vont utiliser une communication
dans son gère parfois des seins en 2018
disclose mène une contre-inquête sur la
mort de Zineb Redouane à Marseille
soudain la femme âgée de 80 ans est
touchée au visage par une grenade
lacrymogène cette femme de 80 ans a
succomber à un tir de grenade
lacrymogène reçu en plein visage dans
son appartement alors qu'une
manifestation de gilets jaunes se tenait
en bas de chez elle après la polémique
le ministère de l'Intérieur conclut à un
tiraccidentel or plusieurs mois
d'enquête en collaboration avec un
collectif d'architectes permettent à
disclose de déterminer la dangerosité du
tiers policier la police de police a
fini par admettre que le tir était
manifestement
disproportion que l'attitude du policier
était manifestement disproportionnée et
que il avait manqué de discernement bon
il n'a pas été sanctionné pour autant
mais c'était déjà une première avancée
par rapport au dénégation officielles
antérieur en 2022 disclose a publié 24
enquêtes en accès libre des enquêtes
ayant souvent un écho sur les plans
politiques ou judiciaires je vous
présente tout de suite mes invités pour
ce second débat Sonia Devillers bonsoir
bonsoir bonjour et bonsoir en même temps
ça donne bonsoir vous êtes journaliste à
France Inter et présentatrice de
l'émission les douces le dessous des
images c'est à 19h30 tous les jours sur
Arte fait une quinzaine de jours que
vous avez lancé cette émission Thomas
Huchon bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste spécialiste des réseaux
sociaux et des fake news chroniqueurs
chaque jeudi dans l'émission clique sur
Canal en fait de la pub à nos confrères
dans dans cette émission Fabrice et
pellebois bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste à reflet Point Info
entrepreneur enseignants à Sciences Po
et spécialistes de la guerre
informationnelle et Minnie zappalski
évidemment est toujours à mes côtés
Sonia de Villa est-ce que vous vous
dites que c'est de plus en plus
compliqué de faire notre métier même de
journaliste de faire le tri entre les
vrais et les fausses images c'est un
défi supplémentaire pour nous alors en
termes le volume et d'accélération
évidemment et c'est pas nouveau et ça ne
fait qu'empirer évidemment je pense que
il faut quand même rappeler que depuis
que l'image existe l'image est manipulée
manipulable et perçu comme tel
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il n'y a pas une
génération je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
est regardé nous tous par trois
générations de téléspectateurs une
génération de boomer note génération et
celle de mes enfants il faut quand même
se rappeler que mes parents sont nés
avec le cinéma né après la guerre née
après enfin au cœur de la guerre froide
et donc d'une guerre informationnale qui
a largement utilisé la manipulation de
l'image et on peut revenir à quand même
des kilomètres de propagande nazis ou ce
qui a fabriqué l'Union soviétique pour
se rappeler que les images ont été au
cœur de la propagande et la manipulation
des images au cœur de la manipulation
des esprits donc moi je suis née avec la
photo avec la photo retouchée avec les
effets spéciaux au cinéma avec des
quantités de comment dire de séquences
de télévision qui sont restés comme des
grandes leçons de bidonnage dans
l'histoire du journalisme contemporain
et mes enfants
ne serait-ce que la fausse
Roumanie au moment de la chute dictateur
à Cuba qui utilisait des faux contre
champs etc etc bon mes enfants sont nés
avec Youtube c'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui on a trois générations
d'internautes et téléspectateurs qui ont
parfaitement conscience que une image
c'est quelque chose de manipulable et de
manipuler depuis toujours dans
l'histoire des images alors mais il y a
peut-être un grand supplémentaire
il y a un grand supplémentaire c'est
qu'en fait la possibilité de fabriquer
de manière hyper rapide et gratuitement
ou presque de fausses images et des faux
contenu et bien ça crée un nouveau
désordre en formationnel avec
l'intelligence artificielle avec ses
outils on a eu un cas assez récent dans
les manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites il y a une première photo
d'une personne âgée ensanglantée et qui
était fabriqué par une intelligence
artificielle et dont on a douté au début
pour à la fin de se rendre compte
qu'elle était fausse et le lendemain une
photo vraie prise par un vrai
photographe en manifestation que plus
personne n'a voulu croire puisque la
veille il y avait une photo fausse de
quelqu'un dans son glander dans une
manif le problème de la désinformation
c'est pas tant la désinformation en tant
que tel c'est finalement la rupture de
la confiance qui est une donnée à la
fois impalpable et pourtant essentielle
aux démocraties modernes Fabrice
appelle-moi est-ce qu'on peut dire que
d'ici les quelques mois parce qu'il y a
une accélération pour le texte on a
beaucoup parlé on a fait un débat
complet sur tchadipiti dans dans cette
émission on voit que entre la première
et la deuxième version il y a déjà une
une amélioration réelle est-ce que c'est
la même chose pour la capacité de
l'inger
à produire de l'image crédible et est-ce
que ça veut dire que d'ici quoi quelques
mois n'importe qui pourra en faire
est-ce que vous allez jusque là il y a
des détails typiquement l'image dont sur
les tomates instant d'un vieillard
violenté par des CRS était relativement
aisé à des banquets les tenues des CRS
étaient absents pas réglementaires il y
avait une multitude de détails qui
feront que à plusieurs professionnels
notamment dans le maintien de l'ordre
auraient parfaitement pu dénoncer cette
image comme faux avec des preuves
absolument réputées
en plus s'améliorer sur le fait de
n'avoir que 5 doigts aux mains
le problème c'est effectivement la
disparition de la de la confiance ceci
dit on est dans l'un des pays dans
lequel elle a déjà quasiment disparu
avec les États-Unis on est à tous entre
la Corée du Sud les États-Unis et la
France c'est les trois pays dans lequel
la confiance envers les institutions et
les médias a quasiment disparu on a un
quart de la population qui fait encore
confiance
donc fondamentalement ça va s'effondrer
encore un peu mais on fait déjà partie
des premiers de la classe en termes
d'absence de confiance donc quelque part
on a déjà commencé cette transition vers
un monde confiance alors il y a des
milliers d'experts en intelligence
artificielle mais aussi Elon Musk ou
encore le patron d'Apple il y a des
ingénieurs de chez Microsoft qui est
partenaire d'openhay qui est le la
société qui on va dire commercialise
tady qu'on demandait une pause de 6 mois
dans l'utilisation ou le développement
des intelligences artificielles
est-ce qu'il faut appuyer sur pause non
est-ce que c'est possible d'ailleurs que
la méfiance elle est ancienne en effet
il y a une accélération et la rupture
est plus profonde moi ce que je voudrais
simplement ajouter à ce que à ce que dit
mon confrère c'est que
pendant très très longtemps la
manipulation de l'image le trucage de
l'image fixe ou de l'image animée
n'était réservée qu'à ceux qui savaient
manipuler l'image qui savait fabriquer
une image qui savait concevoir une image
aujourd'hui il suffit de savoir
manipuler des mots pour pouvoir
manipuler une image c'est à dire la
question de l'accessibilité à Monsieur
beaucoup plus accessible et c'est
quasiment accessible à tous peut-être
pas pour fabriquer une image extrêmement
sophistiquée mais en tout cas c'est
quasiment accessible à tous en tout cas
la génération qui nous suit nous assure
est déjà très très très à l'aise avec
simplement pour que nos téléspectateurs
comprennent en fait l'intelligence
artificielle on la nourri avec des mots
voilà et c'est ça qui change tout c'est
que ces mots là ces injonctions là ces
ordres
chacun peut le faire il y a pas besoin
d'être ni un professionnel de l'image ni
un professionnel du code informatique
Thomas Huchon je repose la question
enfin je repose la question de la pause
même si Elon Musk a peut-être quelques
arrière-pensées parce que voilà c'est
les 6 mois de pause lui permettrait
peut-être de rattraper son retard bref
enfin ça c'est un autre débat mais
est-ce que le problème avec Monsieur
j'ai posé la question est-ce que c'est
possible d'appuyer sur pause ou est-ce
que c'est déjà trop tard tellement de
gens quand j'ai vu arriver c'est ces
premières images fabriquées par
intelligence artificielle ces vidéos
dont on va parler ensuite je me suis
souvenu du film Terminator vous souvenez
du film Terminator donc il y a un homme
qui vient du futur pour nous dire faut
casser la machine et ben moi que je
Schwarzenegger débarque pour nous dire
casser la machine parce que ça va plus
du tout là les machines ont pris le
contrôle de tout et c'est la fin de
l'humanité mais je sais bien mais mais
du coup je crois que l'idée du l'idée
d'une pause en fait le problème c'est
pas dans l'idée d'une pause le problème
c'est l'idée d'une régulation le
problème c'est que ces univers numérique
sous et échappent à la loi échappe à la
régulation et chapeau à la vigilance des
citoyens échappe au contrôle des
citoyens et et le problème c'est que
tout ça est dirigé par des
multinationales qui n'ont finalement
d'autres pas d'autres intérêts que les
leurs et c'est multinationales sont
responsables de la conversation
aujourd'hui du débat public quelque part
hyper concurrent et en plus qui sont
dans un contexte hyper concurrentiel des
univers les autres donc on est quand
même dans une espèce d'avènement là du
de ce que shoshanas ou bof appelle le
capitalisme de surveillance
effectivement on est là dedans on est
parce que là on parle même pas des
questions données personnelles qui sont
utilisées par ces intergences logiciel
pour fabriquer tout ça en Italie il y a
d'ailleurs des procès qui commencent à
s'ouvrir sur la légalité de toutes ces
opérations moi je pense qu'il est temps
il est grand temps qu'on se mette à
réfléchir un peu plus vite alors il y a
deux personnes qui vont intervenir je
donne la parole à Emily une première
fois et je vous redonne pas je voulais
simplement moi je suis d'accord c'est
toujours pareil les nouvelles
technologies comme ça on a toujours peur
la télé on avait peur internet on avait
peur Tic-Toc on a peur on en parle
beaucoup donc il y a toujours cette
phase de on est très effrayé et puis
après on voit évidemment les besoins de
régulation d'éducation peut-être
probablement et ça il faudra à mon avis
ouvrir ce champ là pour les enfants
parce que de plus en plus ils sont
auprès de ça on le fait sur les médias
mais on le fait pas sur ces outils là et
puis voir ce que ça de positif parce que
globalement ça va nous ouvrir des
chances c'est sûr on l'a vu sur d'autres
technologies que ça ouvrait des chances
sur je sais pas la santé la médecine et
c'est sûr que l'intelligence
artificielle va aussi être utilisée sur
des aspects comme ça qui seront très
positifs qui nous feront gagner du temps
c'est évident sauf qu'on voit toujours
le côté négatif quand quand ça arrive
vous voulez intervenir
profiter du fait que on est sur glycénat
pour insister sur le fait que le
principal problème en matière de
régulation c'est la compréhension du
législateur vis-à-vis de ces
technologies j'ai eu l'occasion de faire
des ateliers pour familiariser
législateur avec la crypto qui est une
problématique déjà mathématiquement
compliquée mais qui n'y a rien par
rapport à l'intelligence artificielle
générative auquel on fait face
aujourd'hui il y a un besoin de
formation interne du législateur le
texte qui a été pondu par l'Europe en
dehors de traduire la peur du
législateur vis-à-vis cette technologie
ne se saisit de rien parce qu'il ne
comprend pas ce qui doit réguler le
législateur aujourd'hui ne comprend pas
l'objet à réguler et donc il ne peut pas
pondre la moindre législation en dehors
de copier coller des textes que l'on
gentiment fourni des lobbies mais c'est
pas comme ça sur l'intelligence ça
fonctionne typiquement les bases de la
base
cette génération d'intelligence
artificielle typiquement le fait qu'on
baigne tous dans l'intelligence
artificielle depuis 10 ans au moins la
polarisation son opinion publique les
bulles de filtres tout ça c'est de
l'intelligence artificielle c'est pas la
même branche c'est une autre branche qui
a une application industrielle depuis
déjà au moins une quinzaine d'années
mais on baigne là-dedans la société a
été profondément remaniée par ça donc on
est déjà dans une société post
intelligence artificielle c'est la
seconde vague industrielle
d'intelligence artificielle c'est un
domaine dans lequel il y a tout un tas
de branches différentes mais on a déjà
deux branches qui ont des applications
industrielles c'est le début de la
deuxième et oui ça va un impact sociétal
considérable on va revenir aux images et
peut-être vous donner quelques conseils
mais allez-y vous pouvez prendre la
parole je prépare Audrey beta qui va
rentrer en plateau de régulation par
exemple et d'avancer législatives
urgente là il y a un vent de panique en
matière de droit d'auteur parce que là
on est on est vraiment
absolu c'est à dire que les machines se
gouinfre d'images existantes pour
pouvoir en recracher et en refabriquer
et se dire que quand elle recrache une
image quand elle en refroidit elle est
nourrie de tout un tas d'inspirations
quid de ceux qui ont fabriqué des images
originelles qu'est-ce qu'elles
deviennent aujourd'hui à une banque
d'image comme Getty qui est vraiment
alors là d'envergure planétaire qui
vient de porter plainte contre un
logiciel d'intelligence artificielle
justement en termes de spoliation et de
plagiaires il est
ingurgites ils ont recréer une nouvelle
image d'accord de façon beaucoup plus
pragmatique parce que les watermark de
Getty les les filigranes que Getty met
sur les images qui sont accessibles
a été reproduit par l'intelligence
artificielle et elle a reproduit une
image en insérant ce fil gras mais c'est
sur cette base là qu'effectivement un
élément unique mais en dehors la
législation roi d'auteur avec les races
la question de l'art des droits d'auteur
etc on y reviendra à la dans la dernière
partie de ce débat mais je voudrais
qu'on reste vraiment sur la question de
la manipulation des images et de notre
capacité à voilà à faire le tri et
Audrey betas comme promis va nous
rejoindre sur ce plateau rebonsoir
Audrey quelques conseils une sorte de
tuto pour détecter les fausses images
c'est pas forcément infaillible mais ça
peut permettre de s'en sortir il faut
s'intéresser aux détails Thomas je vous
donne un exemple avec une image c'était
pendant le tremblement de terre après le
tremblement de terre en Turquie il y a
quelques semaines on voit un secoursiste
grec avec un enfant turc dans les bras
l'image est forte parce qu'on parle de
deux pays régulièrement en tension sauf
que il faut s'intéresser aux détails je
vous l'ai dit alors vous le voyez le
secouriste il a sur son casque un
drapeau grec l'enfant il a sur son
épaule un drapeau turc qui m'ont déjà on
se dit que c'est pas très naturel et
puis en plus si on s'intéresse de plus
près on voit que le secouriste bah il a
six doigts
parce que l'intelligence artificielle a
du mal à représenter les mains vous
pouvez aussi vous intéresser au reflet
ou aux inscriptions qui peuvent vous
mettre la puce à l'oreille même si
l'intelligence artificielle pour le coup
s'améliore au fur et à mesure des
versions une autre astuce alors faire
appel à des outils pour vous aider je
vous donne un nom l'application Forem si
Cali qui peut vous dire
une photo a été retouchée on va voir une
image voilà le cas d'une soucoupe
volante en violet ce sont les retouches
qu'elle a détecté on comprend qu'il y a
superposition de photos l'application
possède aussi un détecteur de clones et
ça c'est très utile notamment dans le
cas d'image générée par l'intelligence
artificielle parce que quand on a une
foule l'intelligence artificielle
utilise souvent des clones pour obtenir
cette fameuse foule autre astuce faire
une recherche inversée et pour cela vous
vous rendez tout simplement sur le
moteur de recherche le plus utilisé
Google vous avez la petite photo vous
cliquez dessus vous insérez la photo qui
vous pose problème ou même le lien et là
vous pouvez remonter soit à la source de
la photo soit aux articles qui parlent
de cette image ça peut vous permettre
d'avoir du contexte ça peut vous
permettre aussi d'avoir la date de
première publication de cette image et
même de tomber sur des articles de
journalistes qui ont fait du fack
checking et qui pourront vous expliquer
le contexte de cette image merci
beaucoup Audrey Thomas Huchon moi je
suis plutôt optimiste de nature j'aime
bien marcher du côté ensoleillé de la
rue et donc quand pour ça je me dis bah
tiens ça va donner du travail au
journaliste aux médias traditionnels
sérieux finalement les citoyens vont se
tourner vers ces médias traditionnels
est-ce que vous êtes aussi optimiste que
moi je suis pas certain mais je crois
que effectivement ça pourrait ça
pourrait vu qu'on arrive maintenant à un
moment où ce qui circule de manière
libre sur internet n'est plus vérifiable
ou pas vérifiable ou peut être fabriqué
de manière presque instantanée est-ce
que on va pas revenir à faire confiance
aux sources d'informations
professionnelles je suis pas certain que
les chiffres d'études d'opinion nous
poussent dans ce sens là et moi-même
j'ai plutôt personnellement le sentiment
que tout ça vient au contraire nourrir
la défiance d'une manière encore plus
pervers c'est et un peu souterraine
certes les médias traditionnels ils se
retrouvent dans un grand tout dans
lequel il y a aussi les médias sociaux
qui produisent en quelque sorte
effectivement mais il y a aussi un autre
problème c'est que vérifier moi je me
suis à faire un peu du travail de
vérification sur certaines images et
notamment une image qui avait été
publiée par le fils de Donald Trump
d'une foule qui suit Donald Trump
effectivement il suffit de vérifier de
regarder un certain nombre de choses
déjà ça prend beaucoup de temps et le
problème qu'on a c'est que dans les
rédactions il y a de moins en moins de
journalistes on a de moins en moins de
moyens pour faire notre métier
l'investigation à reflet vous le savez
très bien c'est ce qui coûte le plus
cher pour pour faire notre métier et
donc
quand les gens veulent plus payer pour
s'informer et que d'un autre côté il
faut de plus en plus de moyens pour
faire le travail de journaliste on est
dans une équation qui marche pas très
très bien et donc il y a une forme
d'inquiétude rappeler que rien ne ment
aussi bien qu'une photo qui est vraie
qu'une image qui est totalement
véridique combien de fois vous les fact
checker vous avez des bunké des rumeurs
en disant cette photo est parfaite et
tout à fait véritable elle est
authentique seulement elle s'est pas
passée à cet endroit là pas dans cette
année-là elle a été recadrée elle a été
redécoupée c'est-à-dire qu'en réalité on
a notamment entendu générer des images
mais on avait déjà tout ça à gérer on
avait déjà mais comment on va faire
demain
on va avoir besoin de 100 300000 fois
plus de facts shaker c'est une équation
impossible il y a l'approche qui a été
inaugurée par Twitter qui consiste à
faire du pack checking collaboratif avec
un algorithme qui a été publique donc et
qui qui tient la route et dont les
premiers résultats sont tout à fait
convaincants et ça consiste à déléguer à
la population générale en évidant et en
notant le la capacité de tout un chacun
à faire du fight checking et en ne
retenant que les meilleurs au fil du
temps ça ça peut être peut-être une
approche qui permettrait de faire face à
cette afflux de fake news on les appelle
comment on veut qui va déverser aussi
bien en terme de texte en
est-ce qu'on peut imaginer un logiciel
que je rajouterais sur mon téléphone
portable et qui fait le boulot ça c'est
du solysme technologique c'est c'est du
cherche un start-up en piste non non une
solution très très bête qui consiste à
typiquement ce que fait Twitter c'est
qui permet aux gens de commenter un
tweet et il permet aux gens de noter de
façon très fine et multidimensionnelle
l'apport de ce commentaire ce qui fait
que très rapidement on va pouvoir avoir
des commentaires qui vont des bonnes qui
a une information ou l'enrichir ou la
contextualiser faire concrètement faire
le travail d'un journaliste prendre une
info brut la constexualiser lui apporter
des compléments d'informations et
éventuellement
la nier si l'information est fausse et
tout ça de façon collaborative c'est une
approche qui elle peut aller au passage
à l'échelle mais on est dans le
journalisme les réseaux sociaux je
trouve que là il y a un autre danger
mais alors vraiment caractérisé c'est
pas tant l'information qui est véhiculée
partagée sur les réseaux c'est qui parle
et c'est à dire que aujourd'hui ça de
plus en plus compliqué de savoir qui
parle est-ce que c'est une personne
réelle ou est-ce que c'est un bot et au
fond les robots à partir du moment où il
se présente avec un prénom un nom et un
visage
serpents longtemps on a été identifié
par nos visages aujourd'hui le visage
peut être entièrement généré par une et
c'est en fait aujourd'hui vous avez des
logiciels qui vous fournissent des
centaines des centaines de milliers de
visages de gens qui n'ont jamais existé
et là aussi dans cette question des
avatars numériques ça pose une vraie
question on sait très bien que Twitter
est infesté de faux comptes et
aujourd'hui c'est faux comptes s'ils
sont incarnés par des avatars avec des
visages des prénoms des noms des visages
ça devient extrêmement difficile de les
repérer alors il y a une vidéo dont on
veut tous parler depuis le début et on
l'a gardé pour Émile les États-Unis
l'intelligence artificielle utilisée à
des fins politiques oui parce que dans
campagnes électorale on avait eu déjà
les fake news les deep fake l'idée de
prendre un visage et de le remplacer par
un autre
maintenant c'est autour de
l'intelligence artificielle de s'inviter
justement dans les campagnes électorales
alors ça se passe aux États-Unis
évidemment ils sont toujours un peu en
avance chez les républicains dont Joe
Biden hier annonce sa candidature pour
un nouveau mandat pour l'élection
présidentielle qui va avoir lieu en
novembre 2024 quelques heures à peine
après les républicains publient cette
vidéo
[Musique]
le monde comment deviendrait le monde si
ce président était relu alors c'est pas
n'importe quel président c'est le plus
faible que nous ayons jamais connu c'est
comme ça que s'ouvre la vidéo alors
c'est totalement fabriqué par
l'intelligence artificielle c'est marqué
tout y est ambiance fin du monde
description assez réaliste images
anxiogènes même le son ça multiplie les
scénarios catastrophiques donc en gros
invasion de Taïwan par la Chine donc
question d'actualité crise financière
toutes les banques qui ferment crises
migratoires insécurité donc l'idée c'est
de c'est de décrédibiliser
et c'est la première fois que
l'intelligence artificielle est utilisée
en tout cas comme ça avec un clip
véritablement construit pour ça les
républicains
attention de ça sur le clip comme on a
pu le voir donc en haut à gauche de
l'écran c'est marqué que ces produits
avec une intelligence artificielle le
problème c'est bien là et c'est ce qu'on
disait avoir la capacité de reconnaître
une image artificielle d'une image
réelle surtout si elle émane de
responsable politique là on vient à une
échelle encore compliquée c'est pas
toujours facile même si on a quelques
clés grâce à Audrey qui nous a donné les
fameux 6 doigts notamment vous en
parliez tout à l'heure il y a aussi le
fils de Donald Trump Éric Trump qui a
publié cette photo de son père donc à la
gloire de son père qui est voilà devant
tous les Américains en gros si on
élargit un peu il y a tous les les
drapeaux c'était le jour même de son
inculpation de Donald Trump donc l'idée
de dire voilà il est fier il est il est
soutenu par tous les Américains et la
photo a fait plus de 9 millions de vues
donc on peut se dire que comme on a vu
elle est fabriquée par ordinateur
en intelligence artificielle il n'y a
pas alors c'est vrai que c'est pas si
facile de voir le détail
mais en tout cas elle est complètement
fabriquée en intelligence artificielle
et elle fait son effet quelque part
quand on a cette image qui a été
partagée 9 millions de fois enfin vu 9
millions de fois comme vous l'avez dit
elle fait pourtant partie des images
potentiellement les plus faciles
puisque il y a en bas à droite de
l'image un watermark donc un signe parce
qu'il s'agit d'une photo fabriquée par
un artiste américain qui soutient Donald
Trump et qui fabrique des photos avec
les intelligences artificielles afin de
le soutenir et de l'aider et de
l'appuyer dans sa campagne donc c'est
facile à débunker enfin c'est facilement
cette forme de création
sauf que c'est utilisé à des fins
politiques en l'occurrence ah mais ça va
être utilisé à toute fin possible on va
voir arriver des gens qui jusqu'ici
n'avaient pas enfin été identifié comme
ni en patte talent créatif et qui une
fois aux commandes d'une intelligence
artificielle vont être en mesure
d'exprimer myriade de choses qu'ils ont
dans la tête de façon graphique et nous
sortir des choses fantastiques ils vont
les utiliser des femmes marketing à des
fins artistiques à des fins politiques à
des fins d'expression personnelle de
citoyens c'est à dire politique et ça va
défaire les et là-dedans la distinction
entre ce qui est vrai ce qui est de
l'ordre de l'imagination ce qui est de
l'ordre de l'artististice qui est de
l'expression politique et ce qui est de
l'ordre du témoignage photographique
issu de d'une tradition argentique va
être très très compliqué
je pense que Trump c'est un peu sa
pratique on l'a vu sur les réseaux
sociaux et la cartonné quand même cette
façon très direct très frontale même un
peu hard sur provocateur en fait ça
correspond tout à fait à ce type de clip
ce type de communication de
l'intelligence artificielle donc on peut
se dire que la campagne américaine 2024
ça va être chaud sur ce sujet là après
les médias les réseaux sociaux il va
sûrement y avoir ça non pour l'instant
on est épargné mais de toute façon cette
image de Trump suivie par le peuple
américain il y a besoin d'une d'un quart
de seconde pour que l'impression
psychologique voulue par l'artiste
arrive à votre cerveau donc c'est
redoutablement efficace et on n'est pas
dans de la faculté on est vraiment dans
dans une forme d'expression artistique à
des fins même si une partie des 9
millions de personnes qui l'ont vu ont
peut-être pris pour une imagerie je ne
sais pas
c'est possible mais bon alors on est de
toute façon
Eisen Stein a été au service de l'Union
soviétique a été au service du régime de
ça on est d'accord
existe ce sont bien sûr
je voudrais revenir sur cette vidéo là
qu'on a vu donc fabriquer par les
républicains ce qui est qu'est-ce qui
vous frappe dommage on l'a rapidité
peut-être là c'est que quelques heures à
peine après la déclaration de Joe Biden
ils arrivent les républicains et à
sortir un produit un contenu vidéo qui
prend des semaines à fabriquer par une
boîte de production traditionnelle et
surtout qui coûte potentiellement des
millions de dollars à fabriquer là les
images qu'on voit sur cette sont des
images si on voit que c'est des très
très belles caméras que il y a beaucoup
de grains dans l'image donc il y a
vraiment quelque part une plus-value
graphique qui est normalement très
coûteuse ou qui prend beaucoup de temps
donc là on a en quelques heures un
mensonge qui est fabriqué de toutes
pièces qui est diffusée
sur sur les réseaux qui est peut-être
cru par un certain nombre de personnes
en tout cas en saura jamais rien mais
finalement le problème c'est 2024 c'est
pas maman
en l'occurrence il y a quand même assez
attendre de mensonges quoi dire que Joe
Biden va provoquer une crise migratoire
et que les mecs vont passer le Rio
Grande et comme c'est montré dans
l'image pardon va provoquer
c'est pas peu provoquer et c'est pas du
conditionnel
c'est un mouvement et le rapidité de
production mais en fait ce temps il va
se il va s'adoudre à un autre problème
auquel on est confronté c'est que
finalement ces gens qui ont partagé
cette photo Trump ces gens qui ont
partagé cette vidéo mais en fait ils
s'en foutent que ça soit vrai ou que ça
soit faux il la partage parce qu'ils ont
envie de la partager ils ont envie de
rencontrer aux autres et c'est ça
finalement qui devient terrible je crois
que c'est ça qui est d'intérim c'est que
finalement on en vient à une époque dans
laquelle et bien je sais bien que les
propagandistes ont fait depuis toujours
Sonia mais où n'importe qui peut dire
n'importe quoi et finalement ça n'a plus
aucune forme de valeur ni d'importance
je sais pas très bien vous parler de vos
enfants je pense aussi au mien je suis
très inquiète je voudrais qu'on parle de
l'utilisation de ces de l'intelligence
artificielle et des images trafiquées
par l'intelligence artificielle dans un
cadre de guerre informationnelle c'est
vraiment votre votre thématique et on va
regarder une vidéo qui est assez
ancienne puisqu'elle date du début juste
dans les dans les semaines qui suivent
l'invasion russe de l'Ukraine voilà
cette vidéo qui circule avec un volet
diverselenski qui appelle son peuple à
se rendre
ukrainien chair défenseur être président
n'a pas été facile je dois prendre des
décisions difficiles d'abord j'ai décidé
de rendre le don de basse il est temps
de regarder les choses en face et
maintenant je décide de vous dire au
revoir je vous conseille de rendre les
armes et de retourner auprès de vos
familles
vous ne devriez pas mourir dans cette
guerre je vous conseille de vivre et
j'en ferai de même
Fabrice appelle-moi c'était il y a donc
un peu plus d'un an c'est assez grossier
on regarde la vidéo bon c'est pas très
subtil c'est pas duré très longtemps je
dis il faut quand même ratio depuis il y
en a eu plein des comme ça cette guerre
a commencé par une facture serpents
c'est une facture
remarquable qui a donné lieu à un mail
un avirus qui s'avance sur une île qui
appartient au-delà un audio on a un
audio des des
Ukrainiens qui sont sur
le chat les Russes qui bombardent et
tuent les soldats en pratique mise en
scène de façon à déclencher de l'émotion
un élan de solidarité vis-à-vis des
ukrainien et mettre en valeur le courage
de ces soldats qui ont défié la Russie
en sont morts et qui ne sont pas
vraiment morts peu importe l'effet
psychologique a été extrêmement efficace
les mêmes ont été un cheval de bataille
de l'armée ukrainienne c'est comme ça
qu'ils ont conquis les cœurs et les
esprits
assemblages d'images et textes qui ont
cette capacité en fait à prétablir un
état psychologique à travers l'image
pour ensuite imprimer un message par
dessus et donc à court-circuiter votre
circuit cognitif normal si c'est utilisé
à des fins de guerre informations
nationales c'est redoutablement efficace
parce que j'ai besoin d'une demi seconde
pour atteindre votre psyché avec ça là
ou avec un article traditionnel ou un
reportage traditionnel en vidéo j'ai
besoin de plusieurs minutes donc c'est
c'est probablement l'arme la plus
efficace pour faire de la guerre
informationnelle ce que les Ukrainiens
ont parfaitement compris que la
formation soit vrai ou pas peu importe
le but on est dans un situation de
guerre et donc soyons pour Angélique que
il y a pas que les dictateur qui qui la
pratique la France s'est bien fait aussi
la France la France héberge l'une des
plus grosses usines affec news d'Europe
c'est c'est les capacité de production
de plumes de 1000 articles par mois donc
on est sur une industrie de
l'affectueuse au service de gouvernement
français on a pensé cette usine
affectueuse pour dirigeant quelqu'un qui
aujourd'hui est ministre dans le
gouvernement Macron donc on est vraiment
dans un état d'avancement du fake en
France qui est considérable on a beau se
concentrer sur les
idiots qui pensent que la terre est
plate ou que la Lune est creuse la
réelle problème il est aujourd'hui à
Matignon et à l'Élysée bon il y a
personne il y a personne pour vous
répondre
donc on va pas citer les noms parce que
sinon sinon ça vous savez j'ai un
problème
Mediapart l'affirmé reflet l'affirmer
Street presse la fermer non non c'est
c'était affirmé par d'autres médias vous
pouvez nous dire leur nom aujourd'hui
pour que les téléspectateurs
toi tu peux le dire moi je suis un
procès avec eux
personnel on a eu chez reflet deux
procès Bayons celui-ci est un sur une
inv application qu'on mène sera le
groupe Altis vous me permettrez de
prendre quelques précautions on n'a pas
une rédaction extrêmement riche et on a
des frais judiciaires qui sont quand
même assez conséquents mais c'est encore
une fois ces informations qui sont
publiques ont été publiées aussi bien
dans médias que dans reflet que dans
Street on laissera noter les spectateurs
les les trouver ces images
écoutez on va pas nous prendre la
responsabilité de si tu es une
entreprise si vous voulez pas citer
voilà c'est c'est pardon mais c'est un
peu particulier comme déséquilibre dans
lequel vous nous placez bref on va
parler des droits d'auteur et des œuvres
d'art tout de suite jouent un nouveau
chapitre comme ça on va on va on va
changer de thème ça va être beaucoup
plus
simple donc le champ artistique je vous
propose un témoignage c'est une artiste
ça s'appelle Carla Ortis elle est
dessinatrice illustratrice artiste
peintre installé à San Francisco elle a
découvert que ses œuvres et celle de
nombreux artistes qu'elle connaît ont
été utilisées par des logiciels
d'intelligence artificielle comme base
pour d'autres créations regardez écoute
je commence à voir l'intelligence
artificielle empiété sur mon secteur
d'activité de nombreux artistes du monde
entier m'ont signalé qu'ils avaient
perdu les commandes cela se produira
rapidement et
ça me surprend qu'il n'y ait pas de loin
pour encadrer ces médias
on parle beaucoup de droits d'auteurs de
propriété intellectuelles mais en
réalité pour un artiste c'est comme une
intrusion
comme un étrange vol d'identité et ses
bouleversant
c'est une thématique qui est vraiment
intéressante donc effectivement
passionnante parce que sa questionne sa
questionne la peinture sa questionne la
photo sa questionne le cinéma moi j'ai
par exemple j'étais déclaration d'amour
l'intelligence artificielle
parce que c'est un nouveau champ de
création qui s'ouvre absolument
extraordinaire c'est un nouveau chant de
création visuelle de création graphique
mais vraiment phénoménal et il y a
énormément aussi d'artistes dans le
monde entier qui sont mais fous de joie
qui ont des yeux illuminés
je suis d'accord avec vous Sonia par
exemple il y avait j'étais au Nikon
signe festival c'est un festival de
court-métrages l'un des films qui a été
primé qui est superbe et c'était
légitime qui soit primé il a été fait
entièrement en images l'intelligence
artificielle ça veut pas dire que la
réalisatrice a pas fait un vrai boulot
de réalisatrice mais les images sont 100
intelligence artificielle pose cette
question là c'est à dire est-ce que
c'est la machine qui prend la main sur
la création ou est-ce qu'il reste encore
un artiste est-ce qu'il reste encore un
créateur et à ce stade de l'intelligence
artificielle derrière chaque algorithme
il y a un être humain derrière chaque
machine il y a un être humain derrière
chaque production de l'intelligence
artificielle il y a une commande humaine
et c'est ça qui est absolument
passionnante et par ailleurs il y a une
longue histoire dans l'histoire de l'art
comment dire de coopération d'alliance
entre l'homme et la machine depuis
quasiment la création de l'objectif de
la caméra des filtres qui qui vont avec
des logiciels de retouche du numérique
bien entendu c'est d'ailleurs ça fait
quand même très très longtemps que le
que l'oeuvre d'art n'est plus forcément
fabriqué avec les doigts et avec la main
et je pense que là il y a des nouveaux
débats qui naissent dans le monde entier
c'est à dire que on a vu par exemple des
oeuvres d'art primées dans des grands
concours d'art aux États-Unis recevoir
des premiers prix des œuvres d'art
absolument magnifique des grandes
fresques en peinture de factures mais
quasi baroque tellement elles sont
classiques se découvrir ensuite qu'elles
ont été produites et pensées par une
intelligence artificielle un autre
exemple c'est un exemple de photo on
vous la propose c'est une photo qui a
été qui a remporté un prix le Sony World
photographe et sa photographe allemand
qui a créé cette photo quand on la voit
on se dit magnifique cliché il voulait
ouvrir une discussion sur l'intelligence
artificielle il a refusé son prix
ensuite c'était voilà il voulait révéler
la supercherie et ça pose la question
est-ce que c'est une supercherie est-ce
que c'est une posture où est-ce que
c'est une œuvre d'art est-ce que c'est
une nouvelle forme d'oeuvre d'art parce
qu'il y a là la démarche d'un artiste
qui l'assume pleinement et qui utilise
une machine comme Tinguely faisait
perdre une machine mais ça repose ça
pose quand même la question des droits
d'auteur quand même parce que si on est
avec une intelligence artificielle qui
utilise des créations d'autres artistes
et sans les rémunérer pour ce qu'ils ont
créé là c'est un autre souci on a eu
quand il y a deux semaines un morceau
qui a été fabriqué par un musicien avec
une intelligence artificielle on entend
Jay-Z le rappeur américain chanté mais
c'est pas Jay-Z qui chante et du coup
bah qui va devoir toucher l'argent sur
ce sur cette sur ce morceau là The
Weeknd a fait aussi un truc la semaine
dernière il faut faire attention avec la
capacité à fabriquer de fausses voies
aussi ça sera aussi un des problèmes
auxquels on va être confronté il y a aux
États-Unis un réseau d'arnaque qui a été
monté comme ça en utilisant en copie la
voix de d'un proche à vous de votre père
de votre sœur de votre frère et cette
voix vous appelle et vous demande de
l'argent un peu sur le mode des arnaques
numériques qu'on connaît bien sauf que
là c'est quelqu'un que vous connaissez
qui vous parle et à la fin vous donnez
de l'argent le Japon vient d'ouvrir un
débat parlementaire sur le sur le sujet
parce que on voit arriver en librairie
au Japon les premiers mangas entièrement
non alors non pas entièrement tout le
monde dit justement entièrement généré
par l'intelligence artificielle non
parce qu'il y a quand même il y a quand
même un scénariste qui donne des ordres
le travail depuis des mois avec
l'intelligence artificielle au lieu de
travailler avec un illustrateur sauf que
les illustrateurs les mangas comme on
les appelle au Japon sont considérés
comme des demi-dieux donc il y a ce
débat absolument passionnant et
philosophique de savoir si la machine
est en train d'avaler le Dieu le Dieu
vivant au Japon et derrière il y a des
parlementaires qui sont eux-mêmes des
mangaka qui ouvrent un débat sur les
droits d'auteur on rémunère qui ont
rémunère qui qui et qui a nourri la
machine en réalité
votre avis là-dessus
Fabrice appellois notamment sur le
peut-être les métiers qui si on parle
des métiers d'images des métiers par
exemple la l'illust les illustrateurs
les les photographes sont des ça va bien
au-delà des métiers d'images tous les
métiers dont la fonction et c'est le cas
tout le monde autour de cette table et
de produire de la valeur avec son
cerveau vont être mis en question et on
va avoir des gens qui vont être mis sur
le bas-côté et puis des gens et ça sera
le cas de la plupart j'en suis à peu
près convaincu qui vont s'augmenter et
qui vont apprendre à utiliser
l'intelligence artificielle et qui vont
l'insérer dans leur processus cognitif
du quotidien ils font des slides des
rapports des comptes rendus des articles
tout ça tchat j'ai pété et tout un tas
d'outils d'intelligence artificielle
peuvent augmenter la productivité la
qualité tout un tas de choses là-dedans
et très machines des tâches les tâches
qui sont peut-être un peu moins
intéressantes
prenez l'exemple d'un journaliste qui
appelle trois experts et qui fait un
article de synthèse les trois experts
que vous enregistrez la conversation
vous la faites transcrire par une
première intelligence artificielle vous
balancez les transcriptions dans une
deuxième intelligence artificielle et
vous lui demandez de faire une synthèse
on lui donnant des indications
structuration du texte tout ça peut
prendre 10 minutes et c'est un exercice
qui prend habituellement 3-4 heures un
journaliste donc le vrai challenge c'est
est-ce que les individus les salariés
vont s'augmenter plus vite que les
entreprises vont se transformer et on va
avoir dans la mesure où il y a plus des
masses de salariés qui sont fidèles à
leurs entreprises on va avoir une
compétition avec des salariés qui vont
multiplier par 10 leur productivité et
qui vont aller se vendre ailleurs plus
cher que l'entreprise qui est pas très
qui est pas forcément le meilleur
accueil et puis des entreprises qui vont
multiplier par 10 leur productivité
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle et
qui vont réduire la masse salariale ça
va être un grand jeu de chaise musicale
je pense surtout en France que les
salariés vont s'augmenter avec
l'intelligence artificielle plus vite
que les entreprises
ça peut être le mot de la femme pourquoi
pas on en avait quasiment pas parlé pour
une fois dans cette édition merci Thomas
Huchon de nous avoir rappelé que cette
réforme a été votée mais n'est pas nous
a fait accepter par les Français bref
merci à tous merci Sonia des vidéos on
vous retrouve je le rappelle tous les
jours sur France Inter et désormais sur
Arte avec le dessous des images qui
était à 19h30 c'est une quotidienne et
plutôt malchance chaque jeudi donc dans
l'émission clique sur
canal je vous dis à demain pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public vous
pouvez également nous retrouver en
replay sur la nouvelle plateforme de
notre chaîne Public Sénat point fr sur
ce public puis aussi toutes les autres
émissions de la chaîne